two stories for you today about French president.
The manual McCrone
one is more serious.
The other one is just sort of funny.
Let's start with the serious one.
I've spoken before about how dealing with
Donald Trump is sort of like dealing with
a petulant child.
Sometimes you have to be strict with them.
Sometimes you have to humor them.
Sometimes you have to ignore them altogether
and do the adult stuff when they're distracted
or not in the room.
And Emmanuel Macron has used some toddler
level reverse psychology to completely get
Donald Trump to change his public tune on
NATO.
Donald Trump, as you might know, has been
denouncing NATO attacking, criticizing NATO
for a very long time.
NATO is a treaty.
It includes 29 countries, mostly for shared
military defense support.
Trump is of course in the UK for meetings,
uh, uh, the for a NATO summit.
And there have been some really good articles
including one in the Washington post about
how a lot of care is being taken to prevent
Donald Trump from ruining anything.
And this includes inviting Trump to dinner
at Buckingham palace and some other festivities,
private meetings with different world leaders,
all sorts of different stuff to try to prevent
Donald Trump from ruining the entire thing.
So Emmanuel Macron, the French president,
took a bit of a different approach.
The French president started last month being
a little critical himself of NATO in a pretty
narrow way, talking about the brain death
of NATO, talking about issues with NATO.
But at no point is it really in question that
Francis, of course, a strong NATO ally, partner
and supporter, but word got to Trump.
Hey, Emanuel McCrone is saying these things,
so what does Donald Trump do?
Well, of course he says, no, no, no.
McCrone is wrong.
Yesterday Donald Trump declared that NATO
serves a great purpose, pushing back against
McCrone, saying that Macron is wrong, and
France really needs NATO quote from Donald
Trump.
NATO serves a great purpose.
And I hear that president McCrone said, NATO
is brain dead.
I think that's very insulting to a lot of
different forces.
When you make a statement like that, that
is a very, very nasty statement to 28 including
them 28 countries.
Check this out.
He even went further talking about how France
needs NATO.
Look at this clip.
Nobody needs NATO more than France.
You just look back over the last long period
of time.
Nobody needs NATO more than friends.
And frankly, uh, the one that benefits really
the least is the United States.
We benefit the least.
We're helping Europe, Europe unites, and they
go against the common fall.
Uh, that may or may not be a foul, can tell
you that, but there are other folks out there
also.
But I think nobody needs it more than France.
And that's why I think that when France makes
a statement like they make about data, that's
a very dangerous statement for them to make.
This is
how you manipulate kids, right?
For years, world leaders have been struggling.
How do we get Trump to stop attacking NATO?
How do we get the president of the United
States to stop undermining NATO incomes?
The French president makes one comment about,
Hey, here's an issue with NATO.
And next thing you know, Trump sees the opportunity
to criticize a European leader and in he goes
defending NATO more strongly than he arguably
has ever done during his entire presidency.
This is the type of reverse psychology that
parents use on toddlers in general.
When a kid is like or five or maybe six years
old, this type of reverse psychology stops
working because it's too transparent and the
kid learns what it is that you're trying to
do on Donald Trump.
It still works brilliantly executed by Emanuel
McCrone.
European leaders all say NATO is good, NATO
is good.
So Trump has to say, no, no, no.
NATO is bad.
McCrone slips in.
NATO is sort of maybe not that great in this
one specific way and all of a sudden a flow,
a switch flips a, I was about to say a flip
switches, a switch flips and uh, NATO is good
for Donald Trump.
Nicely done by Emanuel McCrone.
And now let's get on to the funnier, uh, Trump
McCrone story from yesterday.